-Our next guest
is a Grammy-nominated,
multi-platinum-selling comedian.
His special,
"The Good Old Days,"
is streaming globally
on Netflix now.
Please welcome to the show
Jeff Foxworthy, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I'm so happy
to have you here, Jeff.
-I'm thrilled to be here.
-You had a weekend
very different than mine.
You went on
an arrowhead hunting trip,
which I didn't know
you could even do.
-Oh, I go all over the country.
-Okay.
And are there hot spots
for arrowheads?
-Yeah, there's --
Well, there's places like
where they had better material.
-Okay.
-'Cause I have a farm in
Georgia, but we have quartz.
They're just not very pretty.
And then,
I have friends in Arkansas
that have this beautiful flint,
and they just live in, like,
a hot spot, so we swap off.
They come to my farm and have
fun, and then I go to theirs.
-And what's the process of going
about arrowhead hunting?
I would imagine just looking
down at the ground a lot, right?
-It's --
You would be good at it.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's pretty much --
They had to live near
water sources,
so you're looking for creeks
or rivers and like
an elevated flat spot.
And it's -- like, I would
never dig, like, a grave.
That's bad mojo.
-Yeah.
-But you're finding, like, their
knives and their tools, their --
that, you know --
and some of them --
Like, I've found one this
weekend that's 10,000 years old.
-That's incredible.
-Perfect shape.
-And so you have a farm
in Georgia, you mentioned --
3,000 acres.
Do you find -- are there things
you unearth there on your own
personal farm?
-Not like bodies or anything,
but...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, like I have --
We plant about 300 or 400 acres,
and then I have
a blueberry orchard.
I have a greenhouse.
I have a big garden.
I have -- I started --
When COVID hit,
my daughter bought me a beehive,
and I was like scared to death,
but we started raising bees.
-Really?
-And doing honey.
-And how's your honey?
Is it a tasty honey?
-Oh, my honey's hot,
let me tell you.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-I feel like
I keep walking into these.
[ Laughter ]
-It's good.
-You know,
you live in Georgia now,
and obviously you spent
a big chunk of your career
out in L.A.
-Mm-hmm.
-Being a country boy,
being from Georgia,
like, what was it like
in your years in L.A.?
-Oh, I didn't --
I didn't blend in very well.
When I had a sitcom, we used
to film next to "Seinfeld."
-Yeah.
-And I --
When Ram first came out
with that truck, I thought,
"Well,
that's a cool-looking truck,"
and I actually went
to Beverly Hills Dodge and said,
"I want to buy a truck,"
and they were like, "To drive?"
I'm like,
"Yeah, I want a truck."
And so I would pull in to work
in my truck,
and Seinfeld
would come pulling in
in one of his 50 Porsches next.
He's like, "Zzzt!
Good morning, loser."
You know, it was...
[ Laughter ]
So, yeah.
-Yeah. Well, you stuck by --
You stuck by
what was true for you.
-I did. I did.
I stuck to my roots.
-So, 40 -- you've been doing
comedy for 40 years, and I'm --
I haven't been doing it that
long, but I'm still --
I have been doing it a while,
and one of the funniest things
to me is when you can
still be wrong about a joke
until you do it --
you find out when you do it
in front of an audience.
Do you still find that
40 years in?
-Yeah, I --
'Cause I've done it
in every form.
I've done page-a-day calendars
for 30-something years.
I've written 20-something books.
Stand-up, the thing that
fascinates me about it is...
if you laid carpet for 30 years,
you would know,
"Hey, when I get to the corner,
this is what I do."
After 30,
I still don't know
what people are gonna laugh at.
-I know.
-Doesn't that amaze you?
-It's fascinating, yeah.
-And so I don't want to go,
like, on a Saturday night
'cause they laugh at everything.
I want to go, like,
on a Monday or Tuesday night,
30 people there.
[ Laughter ]
And I take boxes.
I take three boxes, and it's --
they're labeled gold, silver,
and "Certificate of Appearance."
[ Laughter ]
And I just have these --
these cards with these ideas.
But if you and I
were walking in, and you said,
"Pick the four
that are gonna work the best,"
I would still be dead wrong
on two of them.
-I bet that is a great --
By doing that
and by giving the audience
that power,
I bet they take it
more seriously and --
-Oh, they're totally
invested in it, yeah.
And I'm like --
you know, like something --
And I can always tell,
the terrible ones
go in
"Certificate of Appearance,"
and I always know
'cause the only person
I hear laughing is my wife
in the back of the room.
[ Laughter ]
But then
I try to argue with them.
I'm like, "Well, did I maybe
not set it up well?
Did you not understand
what I was saying?"
And they're like,
"No, it's not funny.
Put it in
the "Certificate of Appearance."
-Yeah, there's nothing worse
than when they're like,
"No, we get it."
-Yeah, "It's not funny."
-"We hate it."
-Yeah.
-Now, your wife
laughing in the back,
is that because
she's your number-one fan
or she enjoys watching you bomb?
[ Laughter ]
-Loves watching me bomb.
-Loves watching you --
Like, she'll get in the car.
She goes, "That thing about your
grandmother, nobody laughed!
There was no..."
[ Laughter ]
"I told you that wasn't funny,
but you wouldn't listen to me!"
-It's so funny.
I -- you know,
I don't know what your wife's
background is professionally,
but my wife
has nothing to do with comedy.
And so there are times where
she will say the same thing,
"That's not gonna work,"
and I do kind of, you know,
impress upon her, like, "Look,
I am the one who does this."
-"I'm the expert."
-And then I'll come home.
-I bet she's always right.
-And I'll come home,
and I will -- you know,
I'll have an audio recording
of the show, and she'll go,
"How'd that joke go?"
and I'm like, "Not bad," and
she's like, "Let me hear it."
I'm like, "All right."
[ Laughter ]
"It ate it.
It ate it hard."
-All right.
So let me ask you this.
Where do you come up
with most material?
-I think just
over the course of the day.
I think --
Usually, I just have to be alone
and have to be quiet.
-Yeah, you need quiet.
-Yeah.
-Like, and maybe this is why.
I bet I think of 80%
of the stuff in the shower.
-Yeah, it does quiet it down.
-And I have a pad like on my
bathroom counter where I write.
But I have spent
the last 37 years
coming out of the shower
and saying to my wife,
"Is this funny?"
[ Laughter ]
And it's when she says yes
and I haven't even
said anything yet,
that's when it...
[ Laughter ]
But she has great instincts.
I mean, she'll go, "That's --
No, that's not funny."
-Yeah.
And then, you know,
that's the part about it
that is so valuable
is they're closer to what
matters, which is an audience.
-Yeah.
-Whereas...
-Well, and I don't know,
but I always assume
the audience is right.
If they say it's not funny...
-Yes, I agree.
-You know, and sometimes you'll
throw something out you think,
"This is stupid," and then
people snot on themselves,
and you're like, "Really?
Really? That's funny?"
So I guess stand-up is --
that's why it's fascinating.
It's like -- to me, it's like
the woman I can't figure out,
-Yeah.
-You know?
-Which makes her
really interesting
because I can never
quite figure her out.
-I think that is --
that's a good way of saying it.
You talk about the --
This is --
You've talked obviously a lot
about the process of writing,
but, also,
there's the performance of it.
And you talk about one of the
dangers of having a big meal
before a show,
and I'm assuming
this is something that
you learned from experience.
-Well, yes.
Well, like, for me,
I feel like
it makes you sluggish,
so I never eat before a show.
I'm always hungry.
But I did a lot of things
with Larry the Cable Guy.
And so, we're up in Chicago,
and I sit --
And we were doing a show
together in a theater,
and I said, "Have you ever had
Chicago pizza?"
"I don't like it.
I only like New York pizza."
And I said,
"Well, have you ever tried it?"
"No, never tried it."
I said, "Well, dude,
you got to try it before..."
So I get my phone.
There's a Lou Malnati's,
you know?
-Yeah, the best.
-Love Lou -- love Lou's.
"But I love New York pizza!"
So I call Lou Malnati's,
and they actually deliver it
to the theater door.
Well, anybody -- this thing's
like eating a slice of pie.
-Yeah.
-I mean, it's like that thick.
-It's like a pizza high-rise.
-Yeah, it's a pizza high-rise.
So you can -- I mean, even if
I'm hungry, I can only eat one.
-Yeah.
-So, I cut Larry a slice.
I said, "Here, just try it."
"That's pretty good
right there."
He ate three quarters
of the pizza,
and then he went on stage --
"Jeff made me eat this pizza,
and I'm..."
[ Laughter ]
Burping into the microphone,
and...
[ Laughter ]
-Well, a cautionary tale,
A cautionary tale.
-Yes.
-Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
Congratulations on the special
and the entire career.
It's an honor.
You guys, Jeff Foxworthy.
"The Good Old Days" is streaming
globally on Netflix now.